vous souvenez-vous d'un reportage sur
des gens qui vivent avec un trouble du
spectre de l'autisme et qui suivait une
formation pour devenir commis d'épicerie
c'était à l'été 2021 on en regardant un
extrait
[Musique]
de 63 ans qui a peut-être le plus
enthousiaste motivé veut vraiment un
emploi regard
[Musique]
Diane et Fabienne accompagnent les
étudiants pendant les 9 mois que dure la
formation on réalise au fur et à mesure
depuis septembre que chaque participant
a gagné en confiance
poursuit sa formation au maxi de son
quartier aujourd'hui plusieurs tâches
l'attentes c'est quoi la partie travail
que tu préfères chercher les paniers
c'est pas difficile à manipuler
au debbé c'est un peu difficile mais
après ça on prend l'habitude est-ce que
travailler dans une épicerie c'est un
but pour vous premièrement pour avoir
une paye un vrai pays et d'être capable
de faire qui est toujours voulu faire
quand on voit que quelqu'un arrive à
s'identifier comme étant je fais partie
de ce monde maintenant je fais partie
ça c'est énorme
l'épicerie oui j'ai quelqu'un qui est
très social avec tout le monde c'est mon
charisme
j'aime beaucoup les gens en tout cas
[Musique]
on a eu envie de savoir qu'est-ce qui
était advenu avec Pierre on est allé le
rencontrer
[Musique]
on veut savoir comment qu'on va devoir
s'adapter comment comme mon équipe va
s'adapter comment ça va affecter nos
opérations suite à ça je suis forcé que
c'est que du positif jusqu'à maintenant
qu'est-ce que ça a changé pour vous
d'avoir un travail maintenant
je suis inquiète pas on va de l'argent
veut dire c'est toujours de l'argent qui
rentre toutes les semaines je suis
capable de payer malheureusement facture
et aller chercher de la nourriture ici
parce que je suis un cardamome de et je
suis employé donc j'ai des prix de
l'aide et tout ça